21-year-old Julian Lage has been playing guitar since he was five.
I certainly felt like it was no effort to play the guitar.
It's fun. It was really fun.
And it stayed that way for my whole childhood.
The film 'Jules At Eight' gave a glimpse of what life for Lage was like then...
...when people began to understand the talent he had.
People would approach me and my parents.
And my parents are great at seeing through their offer...
...in saying, "You know what, maybe sending Julian across the country,..."
"...do this and be on the city show, maybe that's not the best thing for him."
If they were looking to make money off me,...
...which a lot of parents might have to and... or might want to,...
...I would have turned out quite differently.
Which may be why he didn't release his first CD, Sounding Point, until this March.
I could've recorded when I was younger.
But I think the biggest issue for me was wanting to step forward with more than just the music.
Lage has an original sound according to music critics.
That originality is probably why we are still hearing about Julian Lage.